[Musique]
moi je vais narrer le conte pour les
enfants et je vais faire aussi vivre les
marionnettes dans ce conte avec la voix
qui est propre à chaque marionnette
dis-moi grand père pourquoi les feuilles
tombent des arbres c'est parce que seul
ou tôt le tone you déshabiller la forêt
pour lui permettre de dormir quand on
s'aime petit nous allons être très
réceptifs à la l'environnement on va
dire magique du compte maintenant
lorsque les enfants sont plus grands ils
peuvent comprendre la totalité du compte
et lorsque nous sommes adultes nous
pouvons comprendre aussi le symbolisme
du compte puisque dans chacun de mes
comptes
il y a quelque chose de symboliquement
très fort les enfants ne ne
s'interdisent pas d'imaginer et de rêver
et le ce que j'utilise comme comme on va
dire comme dean guide line pour le monde
magique de posy c'est la citation de
john meyer qui nous dit que
l'imagination a le pouvoir de nous
rendre infini le monde magique de poésie
est une production que j'ai créée qu'une
production 100% française est totalement
indépendante et la librairie le pavé du
canal partagé une même valeur
donc c'est sur ce point là que nous
sommes rentrés